it's grandpa methodology balladeer oh
yeah a look to see Amana day or fatigue
and embrace Oladipo delegate a composer
legate knows rampant reading a Stalag
rock-solid in luck today
look to your calendar since 2006 the
pecan tree village has planted thousands
of trees each year in celebration of
their girls however this is rare in most
parts of India girls are seen as a
burden oftentimes resulting in violence
against them but here in the poplin tree
village the people are fighting that
prejudice in a very special way
mera naam Sampson or Valley Valley may
be blonde tree grandpa Jack Kapoor
service record yapper gel selection
effects are open beta by Johnny Perkins
Lana grandpa took me like bug farts a
pencil Lydia
his grandpa sent me personally and for
each of these girls 111 trees are
planted in Indian culture the number 111
is said to bring success its category
Surat that marry Betty is canon
guarantee he dead varam a food alligator
roasted ham sammich bank EBT Quixote
[Music]
every year the village celebrates Raksha
Bandhan a traditional Indian festival
with sisters tie a threaded bracelet on
to their brother symbolizing a bond of
protection but in this village
not only did they tie a thread to their
brother they also tie it to their trees
is anybody worth of the other time what
Busan or Daegu Joe schemes denim dimple
agave harvest the bidding at the
periodic table aunty Oscar Burton Turkus
ankle galatea what Osaka Osaka Mahalo
die hamara gonca you aparecen jammin me
to go Botanica son complete a particular
taking a horchata keep it bluntly say
yes and this would be so measure her
excetra me hotcha Botcha
or bacio at Manila carnage at a marina
higher level Sam Kim aragaki become a
salmon or mo achieve achieve 600
mandible Quran
[Music]